[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ten minutes before the
Christmas show I'm Eric I'm a BuzzFeed
producer here and I have a timer going
because I'm in New York so I can't be a
part of the livestream but I am a part
of the pre livestream so this is just me
hanging out with you guys for 10 minutes
before the show honestly I don't know
what I'm doing here or what I'm gonna do
for the next 10 minutes re-adjust
arias making this holiday special
because he loves Christmas I'm Jewish
I don't even celebrate Christmas so I
don't know why I'm in trowing this
holiday special but we have we have 9
minutes and 18 seconds left with me and
you this might get boring this might get
awkward this might be exciting we'll see
what happens I'm gonna put this on the
floor and I'm gonna monitor it okay
because I don't want to go over time I
don't want to spend like three hours
with you guys that would be boring okay
so great great I I honestly don't know
what to do this is I'm wearing I'm
wearing a shirt it says God about it I
didn't it's not Harvard I didn't go to
Harvard
God what is what every Russian parent
wants you to go to honestly holidays
let's just talk about the holidays I
love the holidays in when I was living
in Russia we had ded Moroz who if you I
guess you translate it it's not Santa
Claus it's grandpa cold we had we had
grandpa cold in Russia and so coming to
America and seeing all the lights and
eating ginger bread ginger bread ginger
bread houses and cookies and stuff has
been amazing it's like the American
dream so I hope you guys love this
holiday special and you get to enjoy it
and it's gonna be great and I'm rambling
because I don't I don't know what I'm
doing here I don't even have anyone hear
the specials happening in LA and I'm in
New York and I wasn't invited you know
Ari I didn't ask to fly me out so I'm
just I'm just here with you not live so
if you're commenting right now I can't
respond but ask me questions
I'll guess I'll guess what you're asking
how like why why am I here
great question um I don't know what
what's this holiday special gonna be
great question I I don't know I have
absolutely no idea how long is this
holiday special gonna be amazing
question I have no idea is this special
LIVE yes it's gonna be a live holiday
special
I'm not live but in seven minutes and 15
seconds we will be live Wow Wow we have
seven minutes I feel like I'm bombing
right now I do do stand-up if anybody's
ever in New York you can come check me
out and watch me do stand-up this right
now feels like my worst stand-up show
ever because I'm talking to a camera
there's no one else in the room I don't
know if what I'm saying is entertaining
whatsoever
seven minutes you know what this feels
like this I feel like I could turn this
into a BuzzFeed video man spends ten
minutes in a room by himself with one
camera I feel like that could get
inappropriate that sounds like a weird
title but this is hard okay let's see
let's see what if you guys ever seen
whose line is it anyway it's a great
show you guys should check it out
it's a bunch of very talented
improvisers so right now I'm just gonna
look at what I have in the room and see
what I can improvise with so I have a
white chair or do I
it's a white chair I don't know what
else I could do with this other than
what it what else does this look like
well if you guys are commenting right
now tell me what if you were a part of
the show whose line is it anyway what
would you do with this what could this
possibly be wow this is often out out
this off to a great start um let's see
why don't I just show you guys you guys
you guys see these things in videos all
the time I don't know if you know this
this is just paper
and then there's a light how do we get
this cool little light thing right here
there's a light that we can just turn on
and off like this so looks nice and
looks nice and boring like that right
but then if I turn on the light boom now
you want to see something crazy if I
walk too close to the camera
I'm gonna go totally dark because
there's no lights here and I can get
really intimate but you guys won't be
able to see me but like what's up I'm
really struggling over here and I hope
you guys don't leave just please stay
and stay for the next six minutes so you
can watch this holiday special I feel
like like just just please don't leave
because then I'm gonna get in trouble
like Arya's gonna watch this and be like
I should never use Eric again now I
appreciate you know what's-his-name's
job who's the guy who hosts New Year's
and American Idol right I don't know his
name you know who I'm talking about this
is hard to like just stall and kind of
be like stay right here we're gonna have
something real special I'm not that
special thing but I'm gonna just try and
keep you subtly entertained you know
what I'm gonna do this is too hard I'm
just gonna call my mom and have a
conversation my mom let's see let's see
if she has any ideas
stay right there
don't go anywhere I will find you now we
will kill you if you go no I just wanted
you to talk on camera yeah for one sec
oh no that's how many minutes I have
well I have to stall for the Christmas
special it's gonna be live in about four
minutes and I'm supposed to be the ten
minutes beforehand and I don't know what
to do so I just called you I don't know
do you have any ideas what can we do i
tried to play whose line is it anyway
but i couldn't come up with anything
yeah a holiday special it's a holiday
special I think why don't you just tell
me what you're filling out in the form
yeah well thank you that okay cool good
luck with your health care system okay
all right love you bye
well you see guys you could be filling
out health care paperwork instead of
watching me thank thanks to my mom for
helping me kill like about one minute
let's see I'm just gonna do a handstand
for the next minute let's see how long I
can do a handstand err you guys ready I
didn't know if maybe you guys didn't
know this but I can do handstands I used
to have my own break dance school in
Russia if anyone wants break dance
lessons DM me I got you all right ready
you guys can't see my hands can you so
like it could I could be faking it but
I'm not okay I can't breathe all the
blood is going into my head and that's
enough clap it out comment huh how
impressive was that spent like ten years
of my life try to learn that and never
use it
handstands are the most useless thing to
learn in the world you should never
learn how to do a handstand you can
there's no situation you'll have in the
club like you want to impress somebody
you're never gonna whip out a handstand
because everyone's gonna make this kids
a try-hard like you can never ever do a
handstand without people judging you and
like thinking you're showing off anyway
we're on a tangent we have one minute
and 16 seconds left this has been the
longest 10 minutes of my life and
probably of yours but you know what I'm
doing I'm creating I'm creating a ten
minutes that like is so dreadful for you
that when the holiday special comes
you're gonna be so excited and so
riveted and even if it's like average
it's gonna feel amazing so no matter
what happens this holiday special that
turns on in 50 seconds is going to blow
your mind because it'll be a million
times better than what I'm doing right
now we've got 42 seconds left Aria told
me to count down from 30 so that's gonna
be boring as well I'm just gonna count
and we're gonna see how good I am
accounting okay ready 30 29 28 27 that's
fast 26 25 24 this is hard 23 22 21 20
19 18 17 16 15 14 13 it keeps changing
pace 12 11 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
special switch over get out of here
let's go live the date is December the
18th and the place is Los Angeles
California
[Music]
and at this very moment the stage is
being set for a most peculiar series of
events you see four Aria interval ever
since the day he was born there have
been three constants in his life the
first being a fairly concerning
obsession with overstuffed Nutella
crepes the second an unwavering hope
that should he try hard enough he would
ultimately find the one and lastly but
perhaps most importantly to our tale
a stubborn belief in the magic of
Christmas and its ability to bring
people together oh hey sorry sorry to
grab you on your way out
I saw you hadn't responded to the the
Facebook event invite for the Christmas
tree lighting tonight any chance you're
gonna we're gonna see Shaima day there
you think I got time for what are you
you're turning on a Christmas tree I'm
not like people are but we watch and
people are gonna watch yeah you can
watch together we got a schedule here
you understand that I'm sorry I just I
got I didn't I didn't think I guess I
didn't think it through
Christmas you got to grow up you you're
an adult now yeah
you gotta quit you gotta koroa but in
the 9987 days two hours eight minutes
and seven seconds since his birth the
unyielding passage of time has beset
such optimistic sentiment with the cruel
nature of reality
[Music]
however as REO will soon discover this
is no ordinary night for this evening in
this Restless city of dreamers time will
stand still and for a few short hours a
world of wonder and possibility will
become a reality
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi your life is anything alright so
thank you firstly to Kia for this this
beautiful beautiful intro thank you
again which sounds great
and Melissa I guess let's give some love
and appreciation to jion for his uh
roars intro this beautiful song oh hi
there I am got to hurry for a bit there
but hey yes hi there I'm Aria and I'm
very excited to say the following words
to you which are welcome to a BuzzFeed
holiday special live from Los Angeles
California and we are indeed live as you
can tell already
a bit of a camera hiccup but hey that's
part of the live experience isn't it
we've had one dress rehearsal sounds
really fun I got no cue cards no
teleprompter so whatever happens you get
to enjoy it with me
but it should be a very very fun ride
and I'm happy that we all get to at
least experience whatever hecticness may
come along together anyways yes so for
those of you that know me or even if you
don't know me I love the holidays
Christmas Hanukkah Kwanzaa whatever you
celebrate I just think that this time of
year it's the best time of year and I'm
very excited to share it with all of you
right here I don't know however many of
you are there watching there could be
200 100 even if there are 50 or 10 I
appreciate each and every single one of
you taking time out of your holiday
season to be here with us today and
don't worry you won't be stuck with my
face the entire time we've got a very
wild show planned with a whole host of
as many of your favorite BuzzFeed
personalities as we're available and as
I could wrangle into this special we've
got people from shows across the board
like tasting your feed unsolved lady
like worth it better or like I say lady
like already oh we got the try guys
[Music]
but no it will be a very very fun show
and we want you guys to be interactive
and active in the chat because you get
all the power throughout all the
segments in this show tonight we've got
a live taste test where you get to
decide who eats what dish we've also got
a very exciting live tasty cook-off
where you get to decide which mystery
ingredient the chefs have to use in
their dish and we also have a mystery
box slash stockings challenge where you
vote which stocking each person sticks
their hand into and the show will
culminate with a huge live talent show
where you get to vote for the winner we
want you guys to be active and
interactive in the chat let us know if
you're enjoying the show if you're Haiti
and I'm sure you'll definitely us know
it'll be a fun time overall and you know
what you might even see a few BuzzFeed
personalities hopping in the chat with
you already if they have it but wait
about the show see X in the chat
whatever you want it should be a fun
interactive time for everyone and we
want you there with us I don't know if
we have people in the chat right now I
can't really see the chat but it should
be a good time all of those just nifty
little earpiece here that our director
Matt really used to yell at me when I'm
starting to go on for too long which I
might be doing already so I think we'll
just get started with our first segment
which is an iteration off of an old
experiment we once did which is a
watermelon well I'll let someone else
explain to you we're gonna set it now to
our two correspondents live in an
undisclosed location you know her best
from federal like and you know him best
from Twitter its julissa and Fernando ah
how are we doing thanks Aria I'm julissa
I'm Fernando and we're here to do
something that I didn't know we were
doing a watermelon challenge the
watermelon challenge like I thought I
was a correspondent watching people put
rubber bands on this instead we are
going to be putting rubber bands on this
giant ass watermelon on to explodes in
their faces don't you see the excitement
it's been done before but before we get
started our legal department is making a
sign some waivers and there was a
sentence specifically that jump
me and I would like to read it to
everybody watching at home and it says I
understand it participating in this
activity involves an inherent risk of
personal injury and even death it's the
holiday time you know we have to just
take risks so we're gonna go ahead and
sign it now and pass it on to Becky
let's go ahead and sign it we actually
have to sign it Becky they want me to
die
yeah if nothing will happen here
video-description and I'm gonna put my
signature listen if I die you guys are
seeing this just keep my memory alive
you dad for Christmas just keep my
memory alive Thank You Becky
you look very festive today that's Becky
giving out - Becky she is our legal
representative always making sure we
have our butts covered uh so let's put
on these glasses oh you guys can't see
this but there is a bag over the cameras
do you know what's happening do y'all
see this hair yeah the equipment is
covered in plastic
are we so the way this is gonna work is
we're gonna flip this watermelon and
we're gonna put these rubber bands on it
non-stop while the live stream is going
on so while you guys are enjoying all
the performances we're gonna be here
putting rubber bands and then at one
point it will explode so you'll come
back to us checking us in a minute so
we'll just get started and then we'll
tell you how it goes in a minute oh it's
got an X plug we got we're gonna hammer
on the SIA hair there we are back I have
no idea what should be done and oh I've
been doing in the other room
another threesome of rubber bands on a
watermelon it may explode I think that
the liability release or something in
case they got watermelon in there I you
know so holiday season I'd rather not
lose an eye
but throughout the show they'll be
continuing to lace up that watermelon
and so I think you will check in with
them periodically and hopefully we'll
catch it when it explodes if not at
least we'll have a live replay and
hopefully when we check in at least one
of them's alive ideally but hey if not
great live television or a live internet
vision whatever we want to call this
type of thing anyways I guess one of my
favorite days about the holidays is
actually food and so I think it's
at time then we start off this next
segment with it oh that is a very I
heard someone rumbling that was a very
violent knock but hello thank you all
for coming close the door well thank you
guys all for being here for this
incredible a date I guess like the place
very festive well I think it's actually
apt that we start things off a little a
little tasting you know I've done taste
tests with what that is so I think it's
right that we do a little taste test
hoping you're not eating today nothing
that'll make me puke on camera fantastic
tasting bull penis that's what yes
that's why people try aphrodisiacs from
around the world check it out it's not
quite so bad yet what about you anything
you're hoping not to try no I mean I
like eating anything so I'm just excited
to eat I love eating I'm glad you're
here Jen wasn't supposed to be here
originally she came in oh I'm already
good nothing's crawling nothing is alive
I can say that nothing is thanks and
we'll just see what's in there which one
I'm not going in the perfect to me
quickly
walleye skin
a little house tour and we're gonna
throw back to the watermelon except
leave we have an update from them I
don't think it's exploded already but
hey that'd be fun
oh my god I'm gonna take a while yeah
I'm realizing that we're gonna have to
power through this we also I've popped
like three rubber bands already it's a
big-ass watermelon yeah the bigger the
better I heard yeah I saw this video so
Bobby if you guys don't know okay so no
we BuzzFeed already did this before in
New York they are anything in 2016 so we
got the bright idea to see we could do
it in the whale and that [ __ ] if you see
it explode yeah I just show her the
video of the first time they did it and
let me just say I could see why they
made a sign this waiver I'm also gonna
cover my hair like right now it has it's
out but the more bands we put on this
this hoodies going on because which are
not gonna do is mess up my curls not
today we can't curse on this right legal
can legal let me know if curse thing is
okay back to you alright
but ya know and if we honestly if
halfway through we feel like we're not
getting a lot of progress done and we're
gonna bring some help yes of course who
do you have in mind fine someone fun and
strong great listen yes I've never put
first so I've never been in a suit like
this you never have a little painting
gig or something no just wear like short
like a tank top I've had this on before
because I worked with my my
brother-in-law who paints houses so I
definitely had my little painter fantasy
what were you doing what were you doing
first of all the bright idea of someone
doing this was it like I get weed there
before both who was sitting there at
their desk I was like oh let's put
rubber bands on a watermelon like who
did that [ __ ] well the way they framed
it was I wonder how many rubber bands it
takes for Waterland watermelon to
explode oh like how many
yeah same same concept they're probably
listening to it love that little Kim saw
the rest of that so legal should stay in
this room telling us to not do stuff
like this oh I think that when it pops
I'm gonna hold my mouth open oh girl
it's a watermelon I haven't had fruits
in 30 days you know that because I've
been on the strict diet for a video yes
so which is stay tuned y'all thank you
click on the link subscribe don't forget
to share with all your family that's it
I'm done like today is my start of like
a new chapter so I want some fruit and
it's gonna explode and I want it in my
mouth best way to get it in your mouth I
think and we're going back to Arya or
will continuing this all right this
listen stay with us we're fun oh yeah
because I'm have a big head and usually
everything fits me listen these are made
for everybody this er size inclusive
where was that with the call I think
we're going back to this taste test I
showed you guys a little tour of my
beautiful home my winter home what she
just think thank you for having us to my
interior designers Michelle Michael
Chavez and Nicole a guru no no I butcher
their last day everything anyways that
said we are ready to do this live taste
us so the ways will work though I want
reveal the dishes and what's fun is that
the viewers you guys at home you will
get to decide who eats which dish
through a poll so let's go through the
dishes right now so I don't make sure
you know which ones under each each of
these are festive dishes from around the
world that people enjoy and so we have
here oh we have two right here this
doesn't look too bad does it so this is
firstly this is from Scandinavia this is
lutefisk it is stock fish that has been
basic brined in a lie for days upon days
has a nice little smell to it
smell yeah and uh it's it's it's a
little gelatinous and quality but jelly
like this one here is actually a very
interesting thing this here is holid
it's from Russia this is actually a pork
fat that it's been brined in for a while
and typically this is actually otherwise
known as meat aspic and it is actually
normally gelatinous and hard but we
accidentally microwaved it so it became
watery and microwaved and this is pork
pork correct you don't make it sound of
people Thank You Jen please it's the
holidays let's let's next up here I
believe this is star gazing pie from the
UK this is actually it's made with river
trout typically the fish heads are
sticking out but they were very nice and
they chose not to give you the lost love
to ye o Kings head here in Los Angeles
for supplying us with this the nice mad
Pierre South African man great guy just
like never been there on that place
anyways yes we have this a fish pie
essentially stargazer pie from the UK
and then right here lastly we have an
American classic KFC KFC is a Japanese
treat during the Hollies on tree by the
Japanese festive dish so yeah we have
here from Japan I was Kentucky well
we've got KFC from a Kentuckian Japan
we've got here Stark easy pie from
England I believe it's a Cornish dish
and here we have two separate dishes
here we have a lutefisk from Norway as
well as here this is holidays from
Russia that has been microwaved and made
watery so this is basically just pork
that's chewing in its own fat that's
that's going to be fun Hey
Oh white anyways yes so we are now going
to send out a poll so viewers of the
channel 4 poll options you can decide
what does jazz eat what does God yell
eat what does Freddy eat and what does
Jenny vote we're gonna give you guys
three three minutes to decide we're give
you guys three minutes to decide who
gets what in the meantime I have another
treat for you guys wait are we splitting
this and I apologize to our all our
Scandinavian you know what happened I'm
like pork shoulder pork shoulder in it I
wear the Latin food the Platanos where's
the pork shoulder where is that just
sounds more appealing down here keep
checking the poll should pop up in the
top right hand corner the poll is coming
in the meantime while we wait for the
poll I do have a nice treat for you guys
want some hot chocolate yeah
is it hot chocolate is hot chocolate and
then we're gonna spice it up with a
little love I have a little gift for
Noah Fisk on this one we could
appreciate I believe the poll is up
everyone so start voting in the meantime
we will enjoy some of this amazing hot
chocolate and I actually have some extra
ingredients we can kick into this I
believe is the whipped cream available
you guys are my guests oh there you go
this is a nice little precursor to to
whatever is gonna go on Thank You Jess
could you please grab the whipped cream
oh yeah oh wow how much how much would
you guys like him this of this tequila
Oh
oh my gosh all right I don't want
anything I don't for you all right just
I work I just this tiny smell smoke Wow
is amazing that's gay that's good all
right perfect let's uh top it off with
cream on there yeah I'm good all right
what is that this is oh this is
important this is Chef John says a dash
of cayenne no no I mean spice it up a
little bit we got here a little a little
cinnamon you wash your hands right oh
absolutely
I can't see you look at the camera oh
you oh you want more perfect please
enjoy let's give a toast
salut happy holidays all right I'll let
them have a sip but the results have
come in oh I got delightful and Cayenne
whoa that's a kick oh that kind of mad
it's alright the votes are in
thank you all for voting we have our
first reveal the winner of the amazing
pork fat stew meat dish that has been
microwaved from a gelatinous jelly is
nothing has none other than got yelled
as ordered Oh
alright and I think we're way for the
rest of their boats what else we got
over there with you Matt Rio all right I
got Grady Oh
who got the Kentucky Fried Chicken if we
get if I got this I'm gonna be really
I'm upset
so I'm trying the pork chop that's what
I'm trying all right you sorry this
okay so I guess two of you may have
actually lucked out by Kentucky Fried
Chicken oh and I feel very bad saying
that's cuz though one person obviously
it's not gonna be having it well
actually actually if we can get some
good news first no one needs that ate
the lutefisk our jazz and Jenn and
Freddy you get the star guys this is the
first time I feel honored it as I said
before everyone every segment throughout
the show you get to vote on certain
things that happened so thank you for
voting and deciding the festive feast of
them get look at God yeah he's so happy
enjoy I got crispy yes like crispy yeah
I'm gonna get you up we have someone
here honey oh thank you oh thank you
this is all right oh you need one to
take a bite altogether just do you just
one I'm still working
oh good oh there we go oh cool somebody
good
all right now who wants washy this is
actually part of your district you guys
try dipping some of that in this little
horseradish a little I believe Russian
mustard lots of love to Kalinka
oh there you go look at that see what a
plot twist we're happy with the way you
made it sound like it was in the
microwave it is from Russia anyway try
the lutefisk
anybody wants us large Jen I'll try the
lutefisk with you do you have a spare
fork or there you got deal kind of just
discard them all perfect okay perfect
all right Jen Jen and I are gonna try
the lutefisk I'm gonna try the papaya oh
it's like dried fish you would find in
Asia I think you were for it
fantastic bigger than anything else but
yeah this is good Josh you want to share
any holiday traditions you have any
holiday what are your thoughts on the
holidays
hmm well sorry this is the first time
I'm traveling back home for the holidays
in the past like three years so I'm
really excited to be with my family
people oh yeah nice yeah the holidays is
all about enjoying your time with
friends and family you don't get that
all the time throughout the year so take
advantage this year
give a kiss your mom your dad your
uncle's your cousins and your friends so
I found love about the holiday
Freddie yeah I just love it it's like a
time full of love and like care but also
you can be really care for you like you
can just eat all the food and like not
worry about like you know wait and
Internet and social media you really
live in the moment and that's like my
goal for this holiday season to like
kind of stay off my phone and just like
enjoy the people around me that's a good
thing a lot of us are very
technologically dependent hence this
live stream as well but yes maybe make
it a goal I took three drinks and
nothing came out Jen oh no no I just
think the holidays are really lovely
timing here just be with your your loved
ones like everybody we just saw it's
just a nice time where it's like
everybody gets off police you can sort
of home yeah I'm going yeah back to the
Midwest yeah where are you both from
near Chicago same oh wow yeah I say we
toast the holidays Tuesday it is a
Tuesday and I hope all your home added
bun holiday Tuesday like I said before
be active in the chat be active in the
chat we do have a whole host of more
segments where you again you get to vote
on things we have tasty cook-off where
you get to vote on which secret
ingredient and they're not the nicest
ingredients that the chefs the tasty
chefs have to incorporate into their
dish we have a mystery stockist
challenge where again you pick who
sticks their hand into which stocking
and then we have a show a talent show
where you get a vote for the winner and
we got some wild wildly talented people
we love you for watching me stressed
also proud
so thank you very much like the outfit
well you got it from no I got this up I
actually got this an upcoming video
Stephen Kanter Garret Warner shame a day
in any job how badly can you how what's
the worst way spend $100 I spent 3995 on
this tie unnecessary amount of money but
hey they gave me a hundred bucks to
spend and I thought I'll buy a tie
how much do ties cause usually I haven't
I usually spend like two or three
dollars max to three dollars
oh yeah 230 dollars one-time tighter you
get I go to the dollar store usually
goodbye ties goodbyes at I know they
even have them at the dollar store
ah to go you can have anything that's
and a lot of love to Khloe Becky and
Kelsey I know are in the chat right now
I know people are like I said there'll
be a lot of buzz he personality is
hopping in the chat so feel free to
interact with them and I also wanted
that Chloe Becky and Kelsey will be on
the show later and during the performing
a musical number of their own absence
I'll be be supportive and be here for
that it's gonna be lots of fun I've seen
their number it's very festive and
throughout the show again we will have a
whole host I basically wrangled as many
people as I could into this then we're
available and I'm glad that you guys
were here for this for this fun time
this oh look at that
okay let's do this who was a trade
crosses now hasn't had a do you guys
ever any like particularly particularly
memorable holiday experiences you like
to share oh you know what every up
nevermind that's Easter well on Easter
of course which is coming up honestly if
you think about it my family hides a
golden egg and it has money inside of it
and me and my brother like spend hours
looking for it and then we fight over it
it's really sweet oh that's a fun family
about you guys yeah well my family used
to be together because my
cheated on my mom right and they just
separated right so the the divorce right
but before we were all together you know
we'll put music bachata Simon again I
would dance with my sisters my mom's and
my dad so it was a small family but we
all danced with each other to like you
know kind of morning
oh we sing at junk together
it was started from a very sad place and
it happens happen a reminder you can
have a chosen family there are a lot of
people out there that show holidays
don't mean family to that minion your
chosen family and that's okay too
I'm as long as you're spending it with
people that love you guys right and you
got Puerto Rican friends call them real
quick spend time with your Puerto Rican
friends trust me cuz they got something
called coquito that's something you
don't want to miss go great boys oh it's
like oh yeah we good thing when you
Puerto Rican friends spend time with him
you net me we'll never regret it
trust fantastic Freddy and Jenn any
final holiday advice much like God yells
no drive safe let's know Jesse but you
know snow in California that's true soak
it up
enjoy yourself yeah well I want to say
good we're a very final thank you to to
the four of you for coming oh you you
want some more - no you know what you
gave me
whoa we're now very excited - I'm sure
they're very tired - get out of here
oh the food wasn't bad but yes we are
now ready to send you went over to see a
very beautiful performance of an
original Christmas song by the
incredibly talented stool arm that she
wrote -
of her dear France it's incredible songs
if you haven't already it was made into
a video last year it's one of my
favorite holiday songs and I'm so
excited for you guys to hear it
a live performance of it so please enjoy
us along with put a little Christmas
[Music]
waiting under
where do you go
[Music]
[Applause]
baby Christmas song
[Music]
[Music]
when you were young if you hold the
clothes and don't let go you could feel
it in your soul if you just your
favorite Christmas song baby things
along a little spirit and you make
things bright this it's a gift would
given so put a little Christmas in it
say your favorite Chris my song baby is
it better if no body sings along just a
little spirit and you'll make things
right this light
it's a gift would given so put a little
Christmas in it you favorite Christmas
song baby
nooo-body sings along just add a little
spirit
thingies fry eat this
it's a gimboid given so put a little
Christmas city put a little Christmas in
it put a little Christmas in it put a
little Christmas in it put a little
Christmas City
[Music]
all right Wow
Ron applause lots of love to Salaam in
the chat again I can't see the chat but
I hope you have to give me lots of love
- Salam
it's she is such an incredible
incredible and talented performer but
also just a great person and I love
being able to work with her and so I'm
glad she got to be able she was able to
be a part of this and to be here with
all of us for this holiday special and I
guess it's been a bit since we've
checked in with the watermelon so I'm
not gonna send it I'm now going to send
it on over to julissa and Nando to see
what's happening with the watermelon
Nando and julissa take it away the song
we do have the rights to little is
living so I hope you guys liked our ASMR
segment last time I know you heard his
whisper a little bit that was totally
intentional yeah so why would we not
intentionally do that why would we
supposably without telling each other
something while it's live you guys are
watch this crazy so okay I don't know if
you guys can tell what room were in
right now but we're actually in the
unsolved set pretty haunted haunted yeah
you was a show yeah no I don't actually
because I don't want to cry or or die in
my dreams so I rather just look from
afar
she's subscribe but she doesn't watch
pink and purple because it made me feel
like it's not that bad it's not that bad
girl behind those doors
it's wild okay so we actually are not
carrying how many rubber bands were
putting it's a lot it's a lot so I don't
know tell us how many do you think there
are right now I say like 200 200 no do
you think less I think it's probably a
hundred I mean honey Romans do you think
this
is taking right now first of all we've
covered his eyes his nose his everything
he's yeah he looks like Humpty Dumpty
can I say that can wait okay can we
curse we don't we haven't gotten a word
on that so I'll just wait bleep bleep
sorry you best believe I might drop an
f-bomb when this explodes oh I'm so
excited why this why we were in our Bo
Fernando was telling me how he's about
to catch a flight after so literally
your flight is today yeah I'm going home
after this so I need to be on mine now
catch a flight okay yeah you might not
mean for you excuse me hey wasn't my
father oh man just flew ah it's okay
guys
I'm insured no imagine when it's half of
this [ __ ] but half of this watermelon
Jesus it's hard yeah all right when
you're doing this stuff you get all into
it
boy dios mio yeah that's crazy
but um I do predict it's gonna maybe
explode maybe in like 30 minutes or so
30 okay I guess it all depends on how
many rubber bands we put will we finish
the two bags of rubber bands I think so
I think so I think we'll definitely go
through both of these what do you guys
think do you think we'll finish all
these there's I think so I'm gonna put
her put a crown on her for now but yeah
I think we're gonna finish the rubber
bands no you say no I say yes okay well
she not finishing both bags are immense
if we do I'm just before we even get to
after if so we surpassed one I'm walking
off because imagine the pressure one
rubber band one rubber band alone
it's a shits under a lot of pressure
okay do it do it on my back no you gotta
feel it I to have skin on my back
we know
[Laughter]
okay back to the back to the water Mon
okay back to the water man I feel like I
can't I don't think I think you're right
actually now I'm looking back at this
and I'm seeing how many are here it's
like every time we pull one on it still
feels like nothing's happening the bag
is not going down even though we put all
of that on there yeah I also want to
know if somebody could bring in my
stocking for Windows explode in the air
yeah all right you can throw it in your
mouth so when it explode you just catch
it
oh it's like it yes you know you mix it
onto your mouth that's kind of man it's
like taking a shot it's like why I'm on
the shot yeah I haven't drink in a while
so through in 30 days I told you by anti
vs nothing yawning what's the day today
I'm gonna go drink can we get some of
that bottle that you guys have on the
other stage two stage one let's do legal
can we take a shot okay well I guess we
can't take a shot legal just shut me
down she loves doing that so we're gonna
go read phrase and more movements you
haven't no because I feel like that's
the weirdest thing it is you're not
missing out on shutting up sorry
yeah yeah just let it go just oh my god
you are good okay
for cursing accidentally we're not okay
so we're not we're seeing is a no no
okay I mean if they cut the speed you
know what
wait somebody's bad legal is the adult
here we try to say we know okay legal
would agree who was that let me put that
look at that beam said that you know
legal watching you guys will find you
you're no legal once I'm doing let me
get a pig's heart for a video for cut
okay this we gotta go go back back to
you guys
go go go let's finish here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once again yeah everyone please let's
give him a lot of love in the chat
yeah if somehow you're over at the
BuzzFeed sooner you probably see him
walk around he's on a lot of videos but
if you see him yeah hello I know the
snowstorms making it oh my god where do
you practice like these days you know
yeah thank you for being here do you
have things on the tires for snow chains
tangyuan what would you guys like for
christmas special for you I'll stop your
head Oh skating I don't need a man I
yeah don't call me you can now come in
and believe I'll be the chat put a lower
third right here what do you guys want
[Music]
anyway particular like using anywhere
New Zealand I want to see orcas in the
wild or guys
sweet little orcas let's go whale
watching company let us know yeah oh how
cute
are they baby little what's tub what
does it study but makes every big town
all girls like a nub are they born like
that yeah you have a name in mind for
this
hypothetical what about Pina I like
being yet my friends Augustine yet
suggestions let us know in the chat and
Devon will comb through all of them yeah
and who knows you might be the lucky
recipient of so cute but yes thank you
guys for being are you on Daria tell us
you know honestly what I one is actually
having all of you and my biggest gift is
having Gian playing the guitar for me
casa that's what I want I want him in my
house costly just there we didn't even
get him a stool today sorry about that
you can lean yeah you know but yes
that's honestly for me the holiday
seasons just I I don't really like
getting gifts I like giving gifts I have
a very bad habit of giving gifts okay we
will now I'm happy to give you guys a
gift today
well you guys are very excited right now
please come on behind this beautiful
kitchen this is my kitchen island I do a
lot of my cooking here I do actually
cook I enjoy cooking I don't bake though
okay yeah baking is not my cup to you
you you have a great cooking show yeah
well that's good to know there you go
can I check this out I love having Matt
real in my ear cuz every now and then I
hear a voice popping it's like a present
anyways yes so I do have a gift I will
say that off the bat don't worry you
will not have to eat anything that's in
these said oh you're vegetarian yeah but
also in general there's no there's no
eating today is just about receiving
feel yeah are you that's the way we're
gonna do so this is the mystery
stockings challenge I see them filling
them up oh you don't look over there
it's a surprise
so basically this is what's gonna happen
so we've done a Mystery Box challenge in
the past where people stick their hands
into boxes and they try to feel for the
day I think we did a snake and a dog
beautiful we got no snakes here go dogs
your budget did not allow for live
animals that said oh I would love for
there to be well no I should know cuz I
feel like I'm very sad oh yeah I really
want to make that wish happen for you so
please wait out there does have a
connection with food nope okay this is
all explained so honestly I think we're
the greatest of 2018 is with people like
our own re Jackson stave in the
environment you know one of the big
things is uh you know we've been I think
we become more environmentally conscious
in the past couple of years and so this
is a bit of a weird way of looking at it
but I think for me I'm someone that eats
meat but I think one thing that we can
do when it comes to I guess the
production of animal meat and all that
we could learn to at least use all parts
of the animal you know to you know so
it's not doesn't go to waste and so
today we're
and a weird way honoring an animal I see
where this is going
yeah I'm excited I think in our family
we eat at all yes
again you'll not be eating anything oh
do not worry about that you can wait yes
this was gonna happen we have three
mystery stockist coming on by which are
being packed right now and you will get
to know what's inside each one each of
it each of them is a part of a certain
animal and you will get to vote who
sticks their hand into which stocking
and you get to guess which part of the
animal it comes from can you tell us
which animal I can't tell you which
animal actually it is a pig a pig a pig
one of the most commonly consumed
animals and we're going to actually a
weird way like it it's a very weird way
of looking at it but we're going to pay
homage people say that I don't I don't
know what F about sports or we've known
the time our pigskins made I know people
say it in the in the movies films in the
film
so essentially you will get to know what
she is and you're gonna vote who sticks
their hand in each one and if you get it
right just so I'm not too you know wild
I will have to eat the part are you
honestly so look uh your mom's enjoy try
to Devin they were like you better yeah
we're gonna you don't have to eat it
they're like my fakin my fake bacon
bacon I think I do that let the stop
peak okay so actually before we actually
even do break up so off the pole
actually they should actually see it's
let's bring this each one I'm gonna hold
it in front this camera here when I can
don't let him see so we got this is my
god all the lids under there's a lid
perfect thank you very much Michael
Travis everyone oh there's a lid yes I
guess there's also I know which one it
is perfect thank you very much we got
three stockings
I don't know what to do with my hands
okay so you guys won't you guys won't I
want to make sure I can see this up
considering them fairs no no yeah
they're gonna see so this is one part of
the pig and it is a I'm all trying to
read see that let's move up in the pole
- so this part of the pig is one of the
items I can't figure guys
oh no out of my show I don't show Devon
just yet there you go if you see that
there we go okay that's the first one
the second one we've got here this is
all cooks it's not you're not handling
raw meat there you go cuz I was down for
like some chicken thank you Matt Rio
where you go and and lastly we have here
don't look Devon I know you want I know
you're excited to try this here you go
alright so we have three dilemmas okay
and if you can't read it it will be in
the pool so check the pole right now
well you guys three more minutes to vote
who gets to stick their hand into which
stocking and yeah I guess in the
meantime we'll just say pick a fun one
for me don't pick a pick like the
grossest one for me I don't know like do
the can if the can one is boring on one
side you can I'm gonna touch like I
would love to touch it
give me the intestines yeah gizelle try
try and sell yourself to this I guess
try and sell which fun you'd like
yeah here's the thing I I will I will
break your computer speakers if it's
something slimy I'm gonna scream I'll
pick the audio tape your headphones out
take your headphones out or don't vote
for me or just like blind pick one like
an you do on your test you're like I
don't see what would you like I would
like to touch the least animal leg thing
please honor that don't touch this thing
I do want to thank the treatment for
coming because you guys did not know
what was coming
thank you for having challenged very
strongly for you guys at home like you
can smell what's it yeah yeah they don't
smell even like one to me it smells like
I love it like a little heavy heavy
which one do you think of the scent is
coming from I think it's this one right
here I don't
yeah do you guys have any like what are
your go-to dishes for the holidays oh
come on this yeah
my family and I make the money we don't
make them we buy them we're down the
line and they add a mile in like my
mom's like we did find a worm and a
banana leaf women are is last year our
family we're like just throw it I'll
keep going like okay yeah the free-range
them is more protein you know yeah I use
at the mall is so I guess Devon I think
cinnamon bread yeah but I'm having a
different Christmas this year because
I'm going to have Christmas my family
and then my boyfriend's family oh wow
yeah Sinterklaas but it's usually in the
earlier part of the month where they
give each other gifts what's like an
example of a good joke gift oh you have
to write in his family you have to give
it a homemade gift like that has to do
with their year
what happened to them this year and oh
wow did you predict in this this year
last year I did IRA I made this box
because the person I got she was
pregnant so I gave her like an emergency
box that I made but she could crack the
glass and like eat bunch of chocolate
and read the romance now that's so cute
his sister say who is that
oh I wish there was chocolate in this
stocking I know you'd be Oh would you
guys like some hot chocolate
nevermind we threw out the hot chocolate
oh hey there's like some whipped cream
instead okay we have the whipped cream
available oh we do we like the tequila
yes driving no no you're not
alright so I believe we have the results
right now so who will have to go first
I guess I'll I'll give you the honors
we're all going now you only get one
each so no who wants to go first those I
have your results I think Street okay
okay okay
well apparently that is wrong what did
she get oh oh oh you you're one I'll say
it wasn't the worst one all right so
this is what shawntel's christmas
present for me is very Christmas
Chantelle Thank You Ari the first and
last time she ever doesn't get that hand
ready all right Chantelle use your good
one I'm so glad to have not the worst
all right try to guess which part of the
pig this is I'm not gonna be able do
that
I have no idea I look it's an ear we'll
wait for the results afterwards that is
not an ear that is not you yet don't you
got two more guesses do have two more
guesses I'm good you don't stick your
hand in there I'm fine with the here
I'll do this all right so then next up I
believe Maddy can you let me know which
one was it a hoof oh I guess you
actually LMO this was a pink tongue Wow
lengua I think it's it's cow I don't
think it's pig oh okay all right curly
you're up next
oh wait you're think don't work you use
the upstairs bathroom later all right so
this is what curly alright so here we go
[Laughter]
wait what undies you can keep your mitts
yeah yeah they definitely feel like
intestines it's close it's in this
general region it would not be in a male
peg like ovaries no but getting closer
warmer warmer warmer a bagina
I don't know Jana
I don't know what those feel like this
is what those feel like in the time no
no well not entirely wrong but you're
not touching a pig placenta where else
do they live all right
I'll show you guys turn around so we can
see this is this is actually a very
interesting piece and very interesting
piece I think Sean Telo are you making
that noise here currently have a look
have a look emotion our tails gonna get
in the meantime I shall show you guys so
you guys you guys voted for this so you
know what what Devon's getting oh wow
this one's gonna be you're gonna need to
give her heads because it's a very
specific it's a very specific part Merry
Christmas there's no hint that wouldn't
give it away
it's a little wrinkly is no you're not
you're not far off there's some scrotum
in here you're really good um I don't
know that there's scrotum probably not
probably not probably know scrotum just
think the other side was very
supermarket I didn't know you could buy
pork bung but apparently you can yes yes
the tube lining that I guess leads into
all right yes so uh yeah what any of you
like to try any of these i i'm not you
know i'm not i'm not gonna yuck anyone's
yum
I don't eat animal so this falls in love
it so I will go and eat some chocolate
you know I don't really find that muscle
in this oh we can leave it in its casing
I think Oh God
there it is hello Merry Christmas Oh
oh my you know I um you know did we get
it we get a crash zoom on that Oh God
yeah good for you Kevin okay focus
yeah I mean everybody's like like
anywhere else but I think that what was
what did you have done oh I would eat
the lengua and the this thing I think
uterus yeah I chopped it up put it with
some tortillas Sheila oh yeah but this
one I just there should some things
you're like yeah I'm good all right well
I guess that's the best way to send this
back on over to the watermelon it's more
friendly do not yes love the devil on
telly curly we're going back to the
watermelon Nando and julissa hopefully
[Applause]
while Fernando went to take care of some
business I put on my goggles because
safety first you know all right you guys
[Applause]
after a few emails we were able to get
some shots here because we feel
discriminated against and we saw your
comments and you guys were like the
watermelon room is lit so we're like we
need to we need to make sure that we
keep that lid enos that you guys were
talking about Lea and if we're gonna be
here for this exploding watermelon and
if it does hit me in the face I want to
be at least a little tipsy you know no
no no celebration I won't say could you
put that over here legal does want me to
say something for everybody watching
that was the
on condition it was the disclaimer that
we had so bear with me okay we do not
condone underage drinking of any sort
and if you are of age please drink
responsibly hold on
there's some good tequila we're not
sponsored by anybody but I will say a
brand if you tell me what it was listen
no legal the doll team today [ __ ]
really is but you you guys legal it's
fun
this this has turned into the legal
slash watermelon room oh I feel better
now yeah I it's like a heat went through
me not feel like I'm hot bothered ready
to go if the watermelon explodes get it
on me girl and if you skip lunch like I
did you're set but you already are and
I'm just gonna keep it going when I get
to the airport
I'm gonna order a little whiskey I'm
going to dinner tonight
oh where you going I'm going to masterís
for dinner
oh that sounds expensive it's a
celebratory dinner because of this whole
damn 30 days I'm eating how I've been
eating and losing my late so I deserve a
cheap meal shout out I was actually
thinking of signing up to the gym again
I've recently canceled my gym membership
because I got a new iPhone know what I
said if I want this new iPhone
I feel bad spending so much money so I
need a cut cost so I know leave the
[ __ ] because BuzzFeed offers a huge
discount do you know how much I pay
monthly girl work anyways we'll talk
about that later uh I um I also um go
swing my therapist right now what you're
all [ __ ] up I suppose me getting
better for 2019 I am better I know what
a minutes do not goddamn pop listen when
you guys come back
hormones gonna be he's gonna look like a
Kardashian it's gonna be cinched and
look real good okay the credentials have
like they're lowlifes trainers yeah oh
but eventually they go pop watermelons
gonna pop yeah but you know what it'll
be fun it's just it's all the sake of
holidays yeah oh yeah holidays of people
celebrate I would agree with Christmas
you guys soon as well but no tryna
nochebuena yes 24 Saturn afford yeah a
lot of Latin ex people will celebrate
the 24th and the 25th is more like a
you're hungover okay but you know
recently we started we started a new
tradition we married into a family one
of my sisters mo she's my cousin boy I
call her my sister she married into an
Italian family it's become a new
tradition that we do Christmas Day at
her house and it's a pajama brunch I
love that yeah I love when you mix
traditions 24th and we party on the 25th
my stuff that's white so we also
celebrate on the 25th with him because
he likes to do cookies and stuff that
day and on the 24th we all turn up it's
great tradition cuz I'm like you know I
felt left out in the 25th when everybody
on Christmas Day when all my friends are
like I'm like well I'm just gonna like
go to the movies yeah that's what we
usually do the movies and they're like
what you guys I'm not doing it I'm like
dad you always have I already did
everything open them dead last night we
open them gifts that's well we got drunk
now we're good and we're chilling
because today's the day of rest
what if also we adopt a tradition for
the 26 listen listen to more of these
yeah I don't know legals gonna I was
born more become the star of this
BuzzFeed live show put legal in the
thumbnail all right guys back to you are
you
hopefully this watermelon will pop all
right fall from what I understand they
seem to be having a much better time or
they're over there than I thought they
would I was kind of hoping it would
explode by now but that's all right
okay um time will come time we still got
still got time anyways I I'm here at my
house
once again and I found a couple of
guests that popped on Bible Fernando and
julissa we're doing their thing I'm not
Alex
Andrea hey Steve it's actually frosty
today but I'm tasty Watson left them in
the chat if you love their stuff be sure
to send them lovely chat they'll read it
afterwards and I'm sure they'll
appreciate it so yep welcome to boom
what do the holidays mean to the both of
you I love the holidays it's my favorite
time of year
it's all about eating and sharing good
times
oh how about you Ray it's the same like
it's the best time of the year and
spending time with family and it's
precious we're gonna put this friendship
to the test
today cuz I got a very fun idea final
tasty cook-off that sort of came to my
mind cuz you guys have done cook-off in
the past yeah and I thought let's do a
festive one for all of you but of course
with a little twist cuz as I've
mentioned throughout the show if you're
just tuning in it's a very interactive
show where you get to vote in every
single segment you voted on who stuck
their hand into which stocking you voted
on who ate which dish during the taste
test and now here Jenna tasted cook-off
with frosty and Rea you get to vote on
which secret ingredient they have to use
in their dish so what's gonna happen is
they're gonna have about 20 minutes to
basically make a dish they've come
prepared with a theme for their dish but
they don't know what secret ingredients
they have to use in their dish and you
get a vote on which ones they have to
incorporate because we did have I've
invited a few friends to come on by to
taste the dishes they made and we will
crown a winner for the first ever
BuzzFeed holiday special tasty cook-off
and I think we have very fun time so
please be nice yeah I would but let's
firstly why don't you tell them what gee
guys don't decide on a theme together to
make it easy so what is it yeah we
decided to do crepes
yeah the holiday creme cook-off because
they're fun to make and the best
breakfast it's a great holiday breakfast
I love to tell the crepes yeah yeah me
too yeah really overstuffed them but I'm
not offended bananas in them ingredients
so just get that give a simple man load
it up with Nutella if you've ever been
to France those people you know the
French are known for a lot of things but
one of the great things they've done is
they've really mastered the over sudden
acne breakout it's fantastic anyways yes
so crepes that's great so we do have a
panel of judges coming by so you guys
have some time to cook and we'll talk to
the process but I guess for now we
should decide on which will show you
guys which ingredients we have on deck
so uh can we bring oh yeah I'm behind
this do we actually have them ready we I
believe I can go grab them if I don't
need it I can grab them right now
I got the secret ingredient watching
this live stream and I know you guys you
know we don't gotta eat it no they never
said that in the rules they just said
we're making yeah all right I've got
something great for the both of you
start across the frame of hello
okay yes so we have here when we have
three three choices actually firstly
it's ready out here my favorite
ingredient this hazelnut spread
all right this beautiful hazelnut spread
yes here for this dish and then of
course so that's one of the options you
can get them you can give them the
choice of using a hazelnut spread in
their dish or the other two options you
can vote from are these other brand list
items we have here - turkey rooster
fries otherwise well that's a very
friendly way of saying these are turkey
rooster testicles and right here we've
got B beef pizzle otherwise known as
bull penis hazel very if I'm very
creative ways of hi it's like sweating
kind of you know the holidays have other
of you work with penis
all right so I guess I mean I think the
answer is pretty clear but which of
these three ingredients would you most
like to work
okay so we have these three items and so
we're going to basically do what we did
before we are going to throw a pole up
and we give you guys three minutes to
vote on which ingredient they have to
use in their dish again if you're just
tuning in we have here frosty aka
Alexandra a doing a tasty cook-off with
crepes where we have a panel of judges
coming by to taste them and start on a
winner and they have to use one of three
ingredients that you vote for again your
options are bull penis turkey rooster
testicles and hazelnut spread
hazelnut spread so the the poll options
should be up if they're not up already
but yeah I guess well we'll just wait in
the meantime why you guys vote do you
guys do you guys have a preference out
of these two that she would not like to
work with if if one of these two are
pigs
I do you cook this it looks wrong yeah
yeah they're both raw Oh
I don't know if Lanvin is even better I
don't know perfect I believe we may have
cooked equivalents of these like chicken
or something nope we'll find out real
quick if we do have cooked versions of
these I think we may I believe one of
the other stage manners may know I think
he's carrying on over oh yes we do have
cooked it Clement so you don't have to
cook them assuming these are picked cuz
you guys may very well pick you can I
take a look can I take a look at that
yeah because you guys may vary hold it
up so this is so while you're voting for
which ingredient they get to use so this
is the beef one so maybe you want to
vote for that if not you could also vote
for delicious hazelnut spread yeah or
lastly you could vote for the cap yeah
turkey rooster testicles
pungent so yes you guys a little preview
of what the options are we
the wrong label it's not like like a
dog's chicken Miller's you can yeah I
think it's like the mental with my eyes
are tearing up from that it's right that
is summer right oh yeah that's right
well I apologize to everyone that said
who knows you might be lucky maybe
you're all very generous and you'll be
allowing them to use hazelnut spread
probably not I will say that you know if
you're feeling creative whatever
ingredient is picked you're more than
welcome to use the other two as well so
let's say you do get the hints on a
spread but you get creative inspiration
and you want and you insist on using the
rooster testicles feel free to okay well
it was close it was very very close I'm
actually very very shocked
but the hazelnut spread has won with 55%
[Applause]
[Music]
the hazelnut spread so please feel free
to start your cooking I'm excited thank
you guys
well okay now it's time to get down to
business
no more no more mr. frost all right you
guys will start cooking so what are your
prep for a little bit in the meantime I
guess I'll just talk to you guys thank
you again for everyone that's watching
throughout the show if you're still
acting the chat please continue to be so
I believe we still have some BuzzFeed
BuzzFeed errs hopping in the chat with
you guys and they'll still be there
throughout the show until some of them
like Chloe Becky and Kelsey come perform
but yet again every segment so far you
guys have had the power to impact what
is happening and we still have a very
big talent show featuring some very
talented buzz feeders where you
for the winner including there's a panel
of judges that I think all right it's an
interesting mix but it should make for a
very fun occasion while they continue to
cook but again thank you to everyone
that's tuned in even if you've only been
here just now you've been here the whole
time it's been a wild show but I think I
think it's gonna be a fun time I'm
looking for us what do you have planned
yeah so I'm gonna be making a
strawberries and cream santa crib I
haven't made it before but I've made
crepes before just not this one but I
thought it'll be fine I love it okay I'm
going to make a it's kind of a classic
French dessert she's making it fancy
and I make it dancing yeah but I didn't
know the secret ingredients so I have to
gonna be a little bit well chocolate
orange works well together true I
actually sorry hey chocolate and orange
just a personal thing
you know a lot of people like I agree
Wow oh well I'm honestly still a shock
that somehow the internet chose to be
very red instead of the assortment of
ingredients I bought I'm also very
excited for this I do think though that
if you guys had those I really I'm I'm
also a little disappointed out is I
think you guys what if actually found a
creative way to use them I think what I
was gonna do is dip it in chocolate
[Laughter]
caramelized some of their you know
really finely and like caramelized maybe
yeah and like in like the Grand Marnier
yeah probably but please feel free start
doing your thing I don't wanna keep
talking to you guys if you guys are busy
but yeah very shocked you guys were very
very nice but yes thank you again for
voting and for being active in the chat
I have not been able to see the chat for
my experience with streaming I know that
interacting with a chat is an important
part and I'm sorry that I can't be there
chatting with all you but I'll read
through your comments after this all of
them good or bad and I will have a great
time doing so but in the meantime I do
thank you for being active hopefully
it's been a it's been a wild a fun show
so far hopefully you'll just keep on
having more fun if there are certain
people you want to see in the show
hopefully they'll show up like I said
I've wrangled as many of your favorite
buzz feeders as possible based on
availability and who I was able to do
this and after I think several then will
never work with me again after I just
made them stick their hands in to also
do it we ate Rio I'm see I'm hearing
from Matty RiRi that we have guests as
well yeah who do you think judges will
be during the show either way it's good
that the talent shows can be a very fun
way to end the show and I think I'm very
excited you guys to see the performances
we got lined up it's quite an eclectic
mix but I'll be a fun way to celebrate
and ring in the seven days oh yes we are
seven days away from Christmas a wee
Christmas Wow likewise
holiday came up fast I didn't even
realize yeah what do you guys have
planned let us know in the comments what
you guys are planning on buying for the
haul is what you'd like for the holidays
maybe I'll be nice and surprised a
couple of year with those things what a
fun video that would be hey wow I'm
gonna I'm gonna picture that video I
look at my manager when I say that
anyways okay so yeah I thank you for
being active in the chat we're still
cooking away here and we will check in
shortly with the watermelon set but I
want to make sure that they have time to
really make sure that they're not you
know in a dark in dire straits but from
last I heard you guys are seeing it more
than I am I have not seen the watermelon
set but I hear that it's it's it's like
they're safe right now which again
disappointment to disappoint us back to
back no no bull penis we do um do you
make crepes for Christmas probably
because this was your idea to do the
crepes sometimes some of the Christmas I
did and some of the Christmas I did and
you know I can make it like a new
tradition I think so I think this is a
good tradition not easy to like wake on
Christmas morning we usually make
cinnamon buns but that you have to
remember the night before and a lot of
times we don't and then we don't have
anything what is the why do you up in
the white the night before remember
because like if you make homemade
cinnamon buns you have to like have the
dough rise and you know prove it it
takes a while so you don't just wake up
and go oh I'll make cinnamon buns
oh I do love a good cinnamon bun yeah
I'm just gonna put the butter in the pan
we already made our crepe batter because
they're great we're just a crepe batter
is bought done and so they're continue
cooking in the meantime we will send you
right back to Nando and julissa with an
update on the watermelon situation Nando
and julissa please take it away guys hey
I just want to say by the time you see
me next year I'm gonna be fit this six
dollar gym membership thing is legit hey
Julia what are we doing what do we do
what we were not sitting down talking I
went and try to convince legal and let's
just say we check the Constitution and
it is legal we can't take shots with
legal wait the shot I told you I will do
this for you I did it responsibly
responsibly you don't have to do that
legal we know this is Becky she is the
person that will respond to an email and
be like you can't do this you can't do
that to delete that but she's also the
person that will say I'm so proud of you
and I love ya and she also said we
couldn't cast a better better like
watermelon squad let's do this for the
holidays legal Mecca do it by Riva taco
it's okay it's not culture preparation
because we're making yeah you're fine
bajo Centro
it doesn't matter because we took it
anyways it looks in the waste the
cursing is way at the bottom of the list
of concerns I have after this when I
step up the set I think I see HR okay
yeah let's do that let's actually get to
it quick results get it in go to the gym
get it girl get it I mean I feel like
this segment really has changed my life
I'm gonna sign up to the gym I'll go
back to therapy back to mom motivate
people when I talk to them about things
that they should be talked to about also
you're not gonna get anyone really than
me okay so let's do a life therapy
session let's do it a one-minute therapy
session everybody okay so what uh wait
let me just pretend that I'm your
therapist Oh
oh I love therapy ready no just kidding
but uh tell me what's going what is it I
think the reason that I actually stopped
going to therapy is because it worked
and I feel really good yeah I feel
really good about it I think therapy is
actually really cool I love my therapist
and I thought it was really cool I just
thought I had a place where I was like
oh I think I I'm feeling really good and
I'm really busy with work so I'm gonna
give it some time so all of the things
that you are thinking that you
think about you don't think about
anymore no she was great I love her so
you don't want to do your life therapy
session right now with me no actually
now that I think about it really sad I
think I'm doing pretty well so you gas
me up for no reason
yeah I think so
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we're duties for no reason me listen you
probably have a lot of people in the
comments just in town for therapy yeah
support your local businesses y'all I'm
down first also too just so you guys
know I do not wear this what's under to
work I had a jacket on top I gotta just
do disclaimers because y'all
[ __ ] in the comments be saying
some wild ass stuff I said that would be
a problem that work it wouldn't not here
it's not a buzzy boy whatever the hell
you want but that's not my mo what would
happen covered up this is yeah this is
usually what happens at work if
somebody's wearing something crazy they
go up to them and they're like what
video is this for they're like
everybody's ready everybody's ready
they're like they know it's for video
look girl this is my outfit what the
[ __ ] you mean this is just how I came I
showed up ready to get it ready to be
late I feel like I'm it already
oh yeah I'm feeling it I'll tell you
skip one I think that's why I like took
off my thing I was haha
carry on love gone yo ready the over
driver that's taking it to the airport
will be just so happy yeah when I'm
sober it happens on biggest so happy I
don't put my headphones on I just go in
with my phone and I like stay like very
serious I'm just like ha hello have you
ever been recognized in an uber yes
how's that that's weird I'm just like I
don't do it uber pools because I feel
like I don't want to sit next to someone
and then they're like Julie's we're
gonna see where I live and you know it's
too close for comfort but I have had a
driver recognize me and I felt like I
was very thankful that I wasn't going
home because then I would be like a
little weird there you know where well
nobody wants people yeah nobody wants
people to know where you live in general
you know just in general yeah I feel
like I want to be in the middle of
talking and like I'm so distracted
when this blows up yeah they just don't
I don't want it to just be like we're
we're Swiss CIA I want us to be so
engaged in conversation and not all
sudden as to explosion that you weren't
expecting but it's all over you and
you're facing your hair and your
[Laughter]
happened before my world yeah that's
what I get married oh yes of course
everybody that steps yeah we all have
steps and things that boyfriend's need
to go through and levels you have to
have level that give you everything you
want as a boyfriend
why are you gonna marry me you're right
that's why you save something for
marriage you gotta save some things for
marriage and so explosions on my face
are for marriage and that is t legal why
do I let go stop us from this how much
of a job we still have love legal he's
so happy that I told you bring her out
no I think I think they're reading you
in the comments for not taking the shot
but you know what
back to the watermelon I saw the video
of one didn't explode it yeah it goes up
it goes up and at an angle that is like
specifically directed to your face oh so
we need to run this way it's up the last
few ones you're gonna do like this how
do you know when the last few ones are
are you seeing them look at that is
going in yeah I hope that let's try to
show it I hope they see it like look at
the side to me it's going look at it oh
wow
hi Neil Smith and you ordered I know we
told you this is a watermelon but it's
actually an ostrich egg no it's not what
about the credibility you're gonna see
the juices fly when it cracks it does
right yeah all right so I think we're
gonna go back to the main stage yeah we
have some great performances coming yeah
listen come back when I took another
shot who knows
forgot yeah oh and we are back hello
sorry ria was just breaking through her
dishes with me
but yeah welcome back i havent still no
idea what's going the watermelon but
i've you have to here scream
so yeah that said yes we are creeping or
Kreitman over here perfect oh so I
already put hazelnut spread into the
butter
oh that sounds I miss Patrick Lord
Annie John it's Sarah Reuben what are
you doing here please come on over here
wow thank you guys give me a hug hey oh
I don't know I didn't wait yes please
please come on up
I love for you guys to see what's
happening with these two I'll give you
guys an update so you are you from both
familiar with remake Lenny and I trigger
please come on up so so let me say tell
you a little bit what you guys have
missed oh so these these two have been
wonderful and they've been cooking
festive crepes that I would actually
suggest if you have one be great if you
guys judge them
oh yeah not yet yeah but I can let you
know that they had a choice between
three ingredients at the viewers voted
for their the option between a beautiful
hazelnut spread they had the option
between bull penis as well as a
delicious set of turkey rooster
testicles and a minute why are you two
of those things are not like the other
let's make it that way
exactly respectful of all cultures
religions if anyone out there enjoys
bull penis for the holidays please don't
let these people bully you
it's probably a really seems like
does it make them snowballs actually in
the meantime though where we go since
they're still cooking uh festive
favorites what do you guys like to do
eat during the holidays with you well
I'm of the Jewish persuasion so I enjoy
a latke I'm a latke everybody does is
just blanket potatoes so that's what I
enjoy and that's about it
a latke is basically like you take
potatoes and you grate them like so
they're strips and then you you can mix
them with onion you put like a little
pepper salt whatever have you in there
and you kind of make like a little pale
egg make a little pancake and then you
fry it on both sides and it's just like
a delicious potato pancake applesauce
and sour cream yeah with it delicious
hashbrowns rocky they taste very
different okay uh they say I don't know
why I think well first of all like with
a latke you like drain the water from
the potato like you knew that was hot
it's I think it's like the preparation
to take your ending and dressing like
their food keep going keep going
listen Hugh I'm spreading this nutella
or it's right hazelnut spread on right
now I'm almost done you didn't ask if
any of us were allergic to nuts
alrighty emulate to nuts oh my god that
made me nervous really yes if I've ever
stopped at any moment I have a very
blank stare on my face it's because Matt
reality is is yelling at me in a very
gentle manner we all love that
yes okay it's festive treats for the
both of you then Patrick
Danny Danny go for it
I'm a Grinch and I you don't mean that
well I don't mean your girl hey my
family is all care so I don't travel
what's really they eat so she's you and
your dog okay let's make you cringe like
bridges like the real bully type of yeah
yeah yeah I don't feel like you need I
don't feel like you need saving the same
way he did boy oh boy
[Music]
my whip cream is melting melting like a
snowman melts I don't know where it is
and they edit that out so there's gonna
be a point deduction for that I will
tell you what the judges see I'm not
judging anything I'm not taking here
alright that's a bull penis then I mean
if you got it why not yeah yes yeah
these are this is fully cooked all the
way through we work our presentation not
like the discussing someone could do you
have like a foam bucket now we all need
that we won't need a guy I'll just do it
onto the sand
what do you guys been making out eating
your feet lately Oh surprises eh see the
amount of
NDA's I decide before I said I feel me
and Bianca does not play around okay oh
I fear the bulkiness getting Michael is
it hard to cut through the bull penis or
is it going through easy tender tender
hell penis okay good that makes it much
more doable what happens Ria's getting
fancy with her judgement on you
what are you explain what she's doing
sorry
yes I made a caramel made our facility
manager very nervous because they're a
little bit smoke came out hopefully the
that looks great oh we have the bull
penis it Sarah did you know what some oh
yeah I'll take the smaller piece alright
perfect please navigate Oh cold
fatty I can't even get a bite
well I smells great though smells really
that's like it Rhonda for that like my
peeps lied office yeah it's really good
please Annie please use your worth that
expertise to describe the smells that
are coming through to you right now I
took a lot of work to get down but it's
not bad is it was it a mental thing no
no no I can't I can't I'll say this one
more time now that world class no okay
it's very rubbery if I could taste the
flavor very chickeny um the taste cuz I
did it in my mouth she'll have it in my
mouth
it doesn't taste bad but the texture
does make it pretty much inedible
because I try the turkey testicles
instead that was actually not bad either
wait there's two kinds mister testicles
you know when it was bring it on over
that one does need to be snipped up I
just put it down
oh this looks amazing beautiful Wow not
bad though I would really I wonder what
is it lean protein sorry we're finishing
up the tasty ingredients based on I let
us know in the chat based on what you're
seeing which dish would you prefer they
both smell and look great oh my god
anything that jumps out to you from what
you're seeing which dish would you want
to try first
they both gone I just like cooking a
wall inside her because I learned that
yeah the smell is bumming me out no
guitar oh my god it sounds like dog food
with me all right you since it's the
holidays us with a turkey testicle
Rossiter Merry Christmas okay okay it's
like if you've ever how to deliver just
face like liver guys thing on the top
whatever you'd like but you're ready to
start the taste test all the time my god
you make that food that looks like other
things than it is so I do like that oh
yeah I mean to me that represents so
much of my childhood at Christmas just
whatever cartoony sort of like
representation of sugar you can get and
you know and onto a plate yeah that's me
that is just like I feel like I'm in
fourth grade again okay well let's begin
this this judging session so please can
you spin your dishes very quickly to the
judges so mine I didn't have time to
make crab cake but it's a little bit of
a Nutella
first like okay hazelnut stocked crepe
face and then just some berries for this
hat and red some melted whipped cream
for the beard nice what phase of the
wood thing I told me with Priya so I
made a crepe sure that I incorporated
hazelnuts hazelnut spread into the
batter and put like a little Christmas
tree shape as I'm saying guys all right
so please 102 the you could Alec story
if you don't you stay up here actually
anyways like to try first I need paper
towel I need to just hit the turkey
balls off
oh thank you so much all right so wish I
could start first okay perfect we are
running a little behind so let's just
going on in get a whole doughnut yes
Sara Sara please look at this man he
never brought me presents never
understand Sam SANNs comment in the
comment section if Sam's time with a
solid killer's album this was our best
one arguably their best one maybe
all right well alright there you go here
we go
let me get the nose perfect now let's
try a reaiize one yeah you know you
inside Patrick I'm getting it with
orange looks nice and wet which I like
this rule
great job we made everything like you
guys were working very cool great why'd
you guys relieve that you guys are all
in this segment and not the mystery
stockings one or the taste-test
Christmas miracle but still by you guys
then they could have had other
ingredients but you guys were generous
and gave them the tell I while she's
trying but thoughts before we vote I
mean it's like you were comparing two
different
two different like I feel like this is
something you would make it this is
something you would order at a you know
restaurant so it's hard to kind of
compare them they both offer two
completely different you know they check
two different boxes it's stuck it's
stuck Annie
I feel like for some reason Alexes
reminds me of a Mickey Mouse thoughts on
your end um I mean just both very
impressive this is like sophisticated
this is fun so you know I could see just
for different folks all right Sara pick
your pick we got we got one vote for
Alex's I'd they're both wonderful the
only reason that I will say I like
Alex's is just because I'm not a super
orange juice person is very good is just
for me but Patrick I mean I love the
citrus it's all in good fun
alright everybody we are now done with
the tasty cook-off and so now we're
gonna go check in with the watermelon
before I think got a town show with some
fun acts coming up on until then let's
check in with julissa and Nando take it
away guys
so we're scared the watermelon is
bubbling we're done [ __ ] around we're
putting our whole day I can't mess up
the curls the curls are so legit also
also we can smell the crepes just so
y'all know next door next Aria can we
good I knew what he wants so feed me I
like that but screaming do I do it okay
it's looking like it's gonna explode
pretty soon if we're just terrifying so
we're just gonna we're just gonna go in
hey Patrick we have a guest Oleg was not
happy about this legal is shaking it
squirting there's sexual references
that's arguing a shot talk to Becky
all right yo this is gonna happen let's
just power it let's just [ __ ] do it
yeah you all right my mom texted me to
stop drinking she did yeah she said yeah
she said it stupid okay this is
happening how long do we have all right
let's go let's [ __ ] go ham I'm trying
let me see what the six-dollar gym
memberships do for this arm
uh-uh so what's going on huh that's do
you feel these shots the rubber bands
the rubber man we were just told to for
the watermelons further down that's a
walk oh yeah rubber bands Oh sir I love
it do we have a song that we have the
rights to that we could play when it
blows
preferably catches blow from her sting
okay legal is official listen this is
not on MVP is legal but also everybody
out there in the chat saying hashtag CDs
yeah and we'll make this who made this
was it read Rick oh okay we'll be the
real judges 30 days on down the tree
we're still burning up with this grape
all right we came here with the mission
and when you guys Latinos in a room they
[ __ ] get it done they freaking get it
done
peachy [ __ ] yeah actually making a video
how to make these tasty Dom y'all do you
see the water coming out of everyone
coming up every angle this watermelon
sweating what a minute is about to blow
and I wonder what it would be if they
hadn't painted the O go lower they said
to get low get low I could get low get
low get low get low get low
I get low you got it low for that oh I
got a low get low yeah let me go let's
go Oh get it girl I read my suit
we can do this we can do this well take
the crop so we could eat it later
yes save the crepe job shadow legal Beck
a go this one alone is leaking honestly
people are gonna be pissed when y'all
cut out of this room no nevermind
[Applause]
getting excited she's she's getting
excited her basement is flooding she
almost said she wasn't gonna have fun
excuse me maybe those two shots helped
for sure and this watermelon is a tease
can we just say that look at the bottom
this whole things where you guys my
science teacher from high school would
be shook we can do this go go go go ham
I'm gonna try lower
they said lower and we told you we could
good luck while we hold a watermelon
we have a water loan expert that could
tell us how far we are yeah yeah is it
gonna be five is it gonna be 25 I'm
gonna have blisters in my fingers sick
time oh wait I take the kitchen what's
happening now I'm getting impatient
yeah that's it [ __ ] this watermelons
tea thing
let's go you're gonna pop what's
happening not gonna do you're not gonna
make us look bad in front of the whole
internet yeah what's happening here
oh she's like she's a [ __ ] like when
babies don't want to come out they're
like no I'm fine I've been here for nine
months
you're [ __ ] women let me live it's
warm in here it's warm you want me to go
into that world I wanna go into your
world not a great time to come into this
world sorry two things down global
warming oh oh oh that's a rubber man
okay I'll keep it okay okay
if the creams coming out okay okay the
green they know this would be so
stressful it's happening it's happening
this segment took a turn y'all okay
let's do you know what yeah let's go
look I'm tripping up at four we're
losing sponsors all got a powerful water
no where'd you get this Target we're not
sponsored by target watermelon the
people in the sound booth are probably
so upset
yeah we're an expiring we're peaking
sorry dad those first of all oh I can
smell it what yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm so
refreshing actually
yeah a fresco a watermelon I mean we
could get some out of this first yeah
first of all this whole um you guys
can't see but this whole like I don't
know my hold on Dan Tim crap whatever is
wet so can what oh oh wait I see I see
the paint starting to crumb that's one
thing that's why I know it's about
yeah it's gonna pop okay this is
happening let's go that's [ __ ] power
just my mom would be so proud I went
four years to college for this job go
Gators University of Florida Sun Devils
oh my god it's gonna happen like we're
getting sloppy for who cares that six
dollar membership y'all oh oh you see
this cracker oh it's about - it's about
- I'm excited nervous and all of the
above oh she she are ripping she's
cracking its cracking she finished she's
she's coming up see the Hat this is not
a good explosion y'all it's gonna it's
actually not gonna explode look at this
let's have some of this oh yes girl a
chaser oh and this is how you make our
furnace listen I mean am I am I am I you
think give us three more minutes y'all
oh my god the faster it like literally
she's talking yeah I am I am I am I
legal is that okay somebody could make
fajitas on my desk I feel like she's not
quite sure she's lopsided she's not
hurting to get her rope up we have a
whole [ __ ] that's it we got your head
out girl the premise of this world Jesus
we're trying
oh yeah it will pop back to you are you
thank you thank you for me having
goggles are you sweating are we still
here
all right back to you aria we're not
cleaning this right no Aria back to you
thanks for that watermelon community I
just heard a whole bunch of screaming so
I'm assuming it exploded and I still
hear them slightly so thankfully they're
not dead because that would have been a
lot of paperwork to deal with that said
yeah it's been a great show at least I
mean from what I've seen hopefully
you've enjoyed it it's it's been fun
having so many of my friends here at
work come on by to celebrate the
holidays with me and I think it's time
that we really celebrate something oh we
got another guest oh wow it's Ariana
Jackson environmental activist
rreow
well yeah you're covered climate change
is real there you have it from her mouth
itself oh yeah thank you for coming well
I think you're here just in time because
we actually had this very cool talent
show I'm a little bit of you and I
judged it together that's okay yeah sit
down and house you at the couch and
we'll just yeah we can watch this show
together I guess um I guess the question
is like so do you have any particular
talents yourself I'm pretty good at
doing the farting with my armpit but I
don't know if that's a
oh well you know what let's get started
with this talent show and open oh yeah
one more person oh oh oh hey Jane it's
freezing out there what brought you over
I didn't expect to see you tonight
please as you know I am NOT in the
holiday spirit yeah you're pretty
aggressive with me earlier now I'm still
aggressive with you I was watching the
live stream and it looked like you were
all having a lot of fun so I wanted to
come here oh well welcome thank you oh
good to see you
oh wow okay oh yeah that's that's what
your phone let's see how this lives well
oh yes that's us yes oh okay well Shane
uh I guess since you're here yes we have
a talent show would you would you want
to judge it with us okay yes I'm happy
to but understand you're not gonna push
me towards some sort of merry jovial
mood it's not gonna happen
thank you mine not in the spirit this
year and there's nothing we can do about
that
fair enough I hate you made it very loud
and clear to all of us always pulling it
up that's nice right there hair but we
are looking at the chat you know Shane
lots of love for you Shane oh hi
everybody
Wow well hey I'm glad you came even
though you're slightly not in the
festive mood but I'm glad you're here oh
happy - well I'm I'm here and while
you're here well anyway so I guess we
have to show up here live in the chat so
send us our message your messages and
we'll be reading them but that said I
think we Mabel start the talent show
we'll watch right here we have a whole
set of fun talented performance I would
love for you guys to give your expertise
on them sure but before we start the
talent show to lead us in the they are
not part of the town show itself but
they will be kicking us off we have the
amazing Chloe and Becky Zack sisters as
well as Kelsey and pgk with a wonderful
rendition of a Christmas favorite no ho
since you're old you look excited
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Wow how much how did you feel about that
eh
come on just hit that so much snow up
there is he a smile growing on them add
a face did you guys enjoy that festive
very festive well that was not the first
act of the show that was just a little
an appetizer oh I'm a stranger to
merriment it's a stage of merriment
buddies enjoying this yeah I did enjoy
it that's a great scarf by the way Shane
oh I think it was very cold outside it's
a great jacket too alright anyways thank
you we will kick it off through the town
show so buddy see what happens we have
three acts for the talent show three
very different acts but three great acts
from some of our talented friends here
at work and I think I hope that we will
enjoy it and after each act hopefully
we'll pass our judgement but ultimately
viewers as I've said throughout the show
you guys have the power you'll be voting
for the winner of the talent show today
so please enjoy the next three treat
council well you look very excited look
at that I don't know Oh frown until I
meet my grave let's yeah so basically I
mean like for you both if you guys were
to perform in the talent show what would
you guys have performed devil sticks
probably Google search them is that porn
no no deficits bro oh yeah I'm pretty
good at the devil sticks gotcha re you
said you our armpit yeah I'm did bad
fantastic look at where you can probably
do a duet on the devil takes you on your
next talent demon or with the chat is
flying on in playa snuggles wants to
shout out what yours it already doesn't
sing the Buble sushi song well you know
who knows we may still have time for a
special appearance let's see what else
we got here a devil sticks
someone said all Bianca's right shame
you're not fooling anyone I see that
smile oh no no we see that is really old
chunk of coal not after this town so
we're gonna we're gonna turn that frown
upside down make a try are you're happy
though thank you for being happy with
this alright looks like we're ready for
our first
of the talent show so I'm very excited
to send us on over there we have now
this is a very exciting man his name is
Stuart Goldstein and he is our general
counsel you know he is the legal man and
he's also going to be the the first act
and he says it's not his title what is
this exact time assistant general
counsel Becky I didn't see you here in
the cabin good to see you about you see
over in the corner of the room oh yeah
yeah anyways we're gonna start with Stu
uh and we're very excited let's kick it
away Stu
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow geez Oh steward go see let's go sue
some love in the comments why thoughts
thoughts you're looking happier re
though please I don't start like a
couple of hours beautiful performance
really enjoyed his piano playing the
piano it's a great instrument on a scale
of one to ten how environmentally
friendly would you say his performance
was very environmentally friendly you
didn't spill any oil good but we're the
keys made of ivory yeah anyways shame
your thoughts please you know in the
same way he tickled those those ivories
he also tickled the cold dead strings of
my heart and you know word were there
any room for joy in my heart I would
feel it but unfortunately no I will say
he is a talented man is your heart so
dead oh the way of the world
oh don't we wake up weary every morning
oh who can celebrate Christmas at a time
like this or any holiday for that matter
well I hope this did this show at least
yeah hopefully at least you're enjoying
what you're seeing I'm certainly not
hating it I'm great re are you enjoying
what you definitely enjoy I'm having a
lot of fun
everybody let's give some love to our
Ian Shane for being even those chains
little miserly right now we'll hear no
applause I will not have it send him
some love and maybe I'll turn a turn
attorney whose mood up but until then we
have another performance now we have
here we're we're going to got a
completely different direction from Stu
thanks against do but now it's time for
Joyce Louise Jean with an original
Christmas wrap that was produced by
Adriana Gomez this should be something
very special send them some love in the
comments while we watch this and please
let's shoot on in
[Music]
help help
[Music]
it's Christmas everybody know Christmas
join Jim everywhere we go
hey and we got to plane so it's
Christmas so we do I twenty five twenty
five days till we cut the extra twenty
five days till Santa comes down and we
put it down it's Obama to the haters in
the back cuz you know we bring it back
so you know we bring her back hey it's
Christmas it's back it up back it up
back it up for Shanna back it up instead
of hey back it up for Sarah back it up
and
[Music]
Wow
all right wow that's re I love the
double entendre with ho
Joyce is flawless what our special guest
appearances there by Elena rook and
Claudia Restrepo gomez wow I didn't
expect that what do you think I feel a
little called out when they referred to
haters do they mean simply because I
choose not to partake in festivities I
think they may mean you shame me I have
to do a little bit of soul-searching Wow
but I'm still quite grumpy it's amazing
how this talent show is to come a
poignant turning point no mark of this
video no no oh no I don't know what you
mean oh so you're still not feeling the
oh wow okay so yeah what would you what
was a highlight for that show for that
number for you Ari I think just seeing
Joyce and looking so beautiful and just
really speaking into the microphone with
such power was a very powerful
performance did it did the wit caught me
off-guard she look radiant she
absolutely did no come here I've got in
a good way
yeah great performance a lot of gusto a
lot of guys to a great backup great
backup dancer Shane anything stands out
so much gusto she gave it 110 percent of
my friend she absolutely did whoo good
it was and now we have one final act
here for the talent show so you've seen
two great actually fiends Stu goldstein
you've seen Joyce Louise Jean backed up
by Elena Brook and Claudio doorstep Oh
Gomez and now we have one final
performance for you coming a big grand
festive return please give some love in
the comments to some more
Dollaz
you're excited
well no answers to numerous mine
No
I wanna make things right
well a minute
not
take me off your list
Oh
believe me
nature brought ashore continued
if you can
Dean I
me
[Applause]
can you take me off your naughty list
hey baby
[Music]
[Music]
sleigh bells
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I try to be
[Music]
oh wow what I have no words
I think Shane's look says it all Wow
project a thoughts Wow some more dollars
knocked my socks off yeah I hope you
guys enjoyed that
the damn thing was so great what else
did I team what else did you learn our
outfit change the dancing the poise
everything it was it was pretty
spectacular you can't deny that Shane
even as a mildly grump you got what I
saw out there a triple in performance
and you know what those aids stand for
attitude attitude an attitude I think
that says it all Wow well you saw three
very different but very great
performance as far as from some of our
incredibly talented co-workers and now
it's time to cast your vote for the
winner of this year's first ever holiday
special talent show the options will be
coming up in the polls shortly I believe
the options should be again once again
to remind you we have Stuart Goldstein a
magician on the on the keys I see a
magician as well though he seems like I
would not be surprised yeah
so Stu was your first option secondly of
course you have Joyce Louise wall with a
produced track by Adriana Gomez backed
by Elena rook and call your stripper
Gomez and then finally we have some more
dollars performing with the Sequoia
Holmes and Kahlan Burke yes have those
three options I believe the poll should
be up shortly I believe someone will let
me know if they're not but I think in
the meantime I mean like do you have any
favorites yourselves not predictions for
who you think they want but for you
standouts I mean we cannot deny the
obvious talent that Stu has that is
something that's a musical instrument I
play a trumpet fairly poorly and to see
someone who has a mastery of an
instrument is always very impressive I
really loved Joyce's rap and her
attitude but I also loved some mode
dollars so I'm sort of it's a tie you
have a heart you have a really hard
choice why you guys make why you guys
make your votes I have actually
we had a lot of our friends here buzz
who that couldn't be here for the show
and so this morning I cobbled together a
little a video package featuring some of
your favorite BuzzFeed personalities
that couldn't be here with some reasons
why as well as set to some royalty free
music that I found online please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
there's a list of things that I could be
improving and I swear I'm just saying it
this time too often love and ended up
and losing mostly it was no one's fault
of mine I know that I can't put this off
till later so I sat down and I put pen
to paper
I don't wanna hit
you better at walking out this door
I don't wanna get any better Leslie and
I don't wanna be
I don't wanna get in
you cry I don't wanna get any pie
cuz I don't wanna get any better at or
walking out this door I don't wanna get
any better at saying I don't wanna be
don't
let's ban a new
new crowd
I don't wanna get any better at goodbyes
don't
[Music]
you
by I'm just wait for the results at this
point but yeah I believe it was a
shocker
I guess it's a I'm a traditionalist I do
love yeah I did let's do stews
performance I I grew up playing the
keyboard piano but never to a great
my money's on some more I'm gonna put my
money on Joyce oh we got an even split
here yeah an even split I guess let's
find out what you guys I guess we'll
find out what you guys decided when uh
oh and we had the results from Mary oh
all right what do we got Matt he's being
very dramatic with you right now Matt
yes what do they win all right so stand
up for this so we can really present
this properly all right ladies and
gentlemen put you in a festive mood
anyways uh I just wanted to say that
thank you both for judging this thank
you all for watching the show and from
voting watching the town show that it's
we're almost we saw a little bit left
for the show but for now we're gonna
reveal the winner of the town show it
was a close very close split but I am
very very excited to announce that the
winner of this year's talent show is all
three all three participants well all
right please thank you very much for for
coming you look happy
d'arnot if this didn't the cockles of my
heart they're warm Daria I don't know
what you've done here today but ah I
don't know what to do our means I'm as
giddy as a schoolboy
oh wow I want to laugh I want to know
your sing wonder somebody song I'll say
oh I'll sing would you would we sing can
we sing you know what there's one more
thing we have to do ah what I'll be
right back okay oh you remarkable boy
Wow Shaima day turned around by the
magic of Christmas
so I guess
yeah I guess Shane's got something
planned in the meantime I guess I'll
just take this moment to thank everyone
that's been a part of this show tonight
I like to thank the cast and crew my
friends here that I've come together and
you all for being here even if you're
just tuning in now you've been here the
entire time I really appreciate it
because I think they're something
magical about all of us coming together
and while Shane's figure out what he's
doing I guess I'm just gonna spit ball
for a bit so bear with me but yeah I
just I love the holidays and I think
that today is kind of a testament to it
because we've all come together for a
couple of hours just to do some silly
fun but isn't that something great like
like life life is essentially right a
series of fleeting moments that make up
the memories that will all look back on
20 30 40 years from now and you know
there'll always be bad times there'll be
bad memories you know I I like to choose
to remember the good I like to choose to
remember the good and I think that if
there's ever a time of year where you
can try to make the best memories
possible it's now it's the holidays
doesn't matter if you celebrate it for
religious reasons for or if you hate the
commercialization of it all there's just
some sense of permeating hope about it
all so this year I encourage you to go
out there tell your family and friends
how much you care about them how much
they mean to you try something new try
something that scares you something
you've always wanted to go skydiving try
try try some bull penis you know
reconnect with a friend you haven't
talked in a while hell if there's a guy
or girl out there that you've been in
love with for ages tell them how you
feel because I mean no matter what
happens you know if the bull penis makes
you vomit you know that friend doesn't
to talk it I mean even if you get your
heart broken at least you tried right
yeah and I think that's what Christmas I
think that is what Christmas is about
it's about the idea of trying to make
your life as magical as possible because
truly in my heart I do believe that life
the holidays love it's all only as
magical as you allow it to be so this
holiday season just go out there and
make your life as magical as it can be
and until then in the meantime
I would just like to say thank you and
wish you and all my friends here very
Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy
belated Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa happy
holidays in general from me to all of
you thank you for being here with me
Shane take it away you know when we
started this livestream I scoffed now I
am staggered by this humble beautiful
tree in front of me everyone if you'll
repeat after me
abracadabra one two three this tree
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
really
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]